tu prends le moteur sabrina là vous avez
entendu il ya un gros animal derrière
renarde il fait un grand moment terrible
tu sais quoi
un gros animal mais enfin casimir tu
sais que tu n'as pas rêver ah non non
non je n'ai entendu et je suis tout de
suite venu vous prévenir
mais il est peut-être dangereux oui il
faut les voir fonds soir ils vont aller
voir le nom attend un petit peu on va
d'abord il faut d'abord savoir ce que
quasi miraculeux entendre alors promet
un grognement d'une espèce de grosse
bête une grosse bête mais c'est pas très
précis ça casimir tu n'as pas une vague
idée de son nom je ne sais pas il
s'appelle peut-être un oscar
morillon coucou jour où j'ai repris une
nounou gazinière c'est pas du tout ce
que je te demande tu sais très bien que
tous les animaux autant cris différents
grâce auquel on reconnaît l'espèce
laquelle appartient la nina ah oui mais
ça je sais oui oui je t'assure c'est une
espèce de grosse ben sedrine a tué
toujours tant qu'être l'axonais alors dû
nous le met à la page des cris d'animaux
d'accord on va essayer de reconnaître ce
que casimir accrue en temps des enfants
venez venez nous donner
jacques olivier olivier vient bien
hélène
mettez-vous là enfin à l'airé olivier
olivier jacques rené là bas tout le
monde est là bien alors casimir a
entendu un cri d'animal tout à l'heure
ouais il sait pas ce qu'il a entendu
vous connaissez des cris d'animaux sains
vous allez reconnaître c'est sûr alors
on va aider casimir à reconnaître le cri
du sien
sabrina oui prends ma voiture tu nous
envoies les cris d'animaux d'accord
attention j'y vais écouter bien
qu'est ce que c'est isabelle isabelle a
dit le no 20 qui aura un tir c'est à
lyon bon c'est ait un autre sabrina oui
écoutez bien écouter ici c'est pas le
sache il ou vous écouter il y pleut
c'est ça ce sera oui mais écoutez vous
écouter un petit peu abandonné les
réponses puis-je vous interrogerez
hockey le suivant alors que c'est hélène
isabelle un éléphant c'est ça c'est à
nous autres c'est sympa ça sabrina voilà
[Musique]
l'appel en mode écoute écoute écoute et
c'est alors qu'est ce que c'est non non
c'est un challenge à st plusieurs
chevaux bon on va remettre nos mails
maintenant voilà teillet
qu'est-ce que ça quasi mi16 pas une moto
m
petit chat qu'on caresse qui ronronne
moto bon allez autre job mais comme un
cheval s'est ainsi achevée mais qu'on
n'est pas tout de suite parce que par
exemple agnès la plus petite elle n'a
pas le temps de réfléchir
et alors pour une écoute en silence et à
la fin on a des réponses jambes et d'où
tu remets un autre évidemment alors en
l'air nigeria les légumes clair qu'est
ce que c'est semana sa belle et amman un
autre encore
[Musique]
il s'appelle à cochons c'est ça c'est
des cochons qu'elle est trop
un agneau encore une autre série n'a
[Musique]
alors que ses passagers ben non c'est
pas une grenouille
jacques hélias à un couple séparé
travaux olivier c'est un animal qui vit
dans un pays très froid s'est pas loupé
presque phoques afin est un fuck
on doit aussi encore et encore et c'est
gagné
je trouvais désigné qu'est ce que c'est
ça m'a prouvé -et non retour et attend
le relais pour la vie qui thunder bay on
l'invité à graver ses biens est bien là
casimir ouais c'est fini on arrêter
cette brigade est ce que tu a reconnu le
crime et tu avais entendu tout à l'heure
lp ah non pas du tout pas du tout par la
bombe alors il faut y aller 1-1 d'entre
nous le chemin
venez en fait bien attention derrière
mettez-vous derrière cette fait par là
françois hamel et du danger
pardon mais j'ai peur de l'eau facile
est divisée vraiment sur la poignée
les flamands participation
ça me paraît un petit peu bizarre pour
un cri d'animal tiens vous tombez bien
je viens juste de finir ma sieste
j'espère que je vais pas rouler trop
fort c'est un peu mon défaut parlerait
facteurs on n'a rien entendu
on n'a rien entendu tous les spas kazemi
1,5 point au non non non rien du co